so I'm super excited to be here and with
this awesome crowd over a thousand
people in this ridiculous screen it's
just amazing and I want to really thank
the team look and his team for putting
this together
I really appreciate all the effort and
I'm really glad to see we also get a lot
of team core team members here as well
so thank you all and so let's get into
it so today this is gonna be a talk
about the state of view and some updates
since we last time I think I did such a
such a talk was at least half a year ago
so quite a few things happened in
between that time and I'm just want to
catch up with some of the things we've
done during that period of time and also
take a look back at what happened to
2017 because I didn't write a 2017 post
this year I did one last year but so few
was the most starred project on github
in the entire 2017 with over 40,000
stars
game in the year
[Applause]
[Music]
and the growth was phenomenal we gained
so we grew from 7.6 thousand to 37,000
from 2016 to 2017 and then we gained
even more stars got like close to 40
46,000 Counting from start of 2017 to
today so over 100 22% MPM downloads even
better in 2017 so the entire 2017 we got
so this is from beginning of the first
MPM published to the start of 2017 we
got only point 2 1 million dollars and
then by the beginning of 2017 you got
1.7 million and now we're at nine point
seven two million and over 1 million
downloads per month and dev tools weekly
active users
I like this metric law because I think
this is a very one of the most accurate
metrics to to tell actually how many how
many people are using leaders around the
world and we have now over 350 5000
users around the world and in 2000 by
Counting to today this morning so I took
those stats this morning so over 300%
growth since last year and financially
the patron and open collective campaigns
are going really strong so big shout out
to all the sponsors that are sponsoring
VJ s on both on patron open collectives
and one of the things so now that we've
got our open collective with a very
decent budget as well so we're planning
to open this up with a public process so
contributors from the community can
start can make proposals on major
features if they want to spend a big
chunk of time working on a big feature
they can make a proposal and then
expense the pay from from open
collective and we want to all the funds
the open collective will be dedicated
to team and community work so new
releases sings 2017 the latest minor
release is the 2.5 level II this was
made in October and it came with
improved typescript integration you
don't even need to use classes and
you'll still get great type typescript
inference and if you're using vs code
with fader you can even get type
inference without using typescript at
all improved error handling we now have
the error captured hook combined with an
after I component you can create error
boundary components that can capture the
error from a subtree of your application
which opens up a lot of interesting
possibilities for error handling and we
also now support functional component in
single file components now core was only
a small part of the ecosystem last year
one thing I wanted to mention is view is
growing too has has already grown beyond
a single person project although I work
mostly on DJ escort there are a lot of
other important projects in the
ecosystem that are maintained by core
team members for example yes link
plugging view it's a it's a pretty big
effort because it involved writing an
entire custom parser from the ground up
called few es link parser that replaces
es lunes default parser and it is able
to link single file view components and
even catch syntax errors in your
templates at compile time so this is a
bit effort and major shout out to macau
and tar roof for working on this they've
been working really hard on yes plug es
link locking view and I think it's a
it's something that greatly boost stiff
the confidence when you're working on
View during the development phase and
then we also have the official view
tested tools which was born out of a
burrow it is a testing library by at
yeah Bert
who I think is probably also here so big
shout out to Ed and tes utils is
currently in one point of beta and you
can already test it out we have
comprehensive tutorials and there are
even more painless ways to use it which
I will talk about later and then a short
while ago we also released a mate for
another 4.0 major release for the view
dev tools great improvements coming into
view dev tools with a lot of new
features including editable state
inspector you can directly edit your
state in the dev tools and things will
reflect back into your app and all these
great features
thanks to gand and he's also here so big
shout out to Jian for working on this
and we also show a logo released an
official news source at news toffee J so
already so this is the official
newsletter that you can sign up to and
we have a curated list of latest things
going on in the view ecosystem plus Greg
and Adam from view mash tree also
produces a podcast episode for each
newsletter so that if you prefer to
listen to something instead of reading
it like where you're driving this is on
another great option and outside of the
core team I'm even more excited about
the whole ecosystem because just in the
past few weeks some great things are
happening across the ecosystem and I
think it's a sign that the ecosystem is
maturing next reached 1.0 a short while
ago in January so I want to say a big
congratulations to the shuffelin
brothers for making this work that is
fantastic
our fracturing on top of view that
provides a very streamlined experience
for making building server-side
rendering apps and they'll talk about it
in details later today just three days
ago
beautify one of the probably one of the
best component UI libraries around in
the view ecosystem also just reached 1.0
so congrats to John for
making this milestone and there he also
has a pretty successful patreon campaign
going on so I would encourage anyone
who's found beautiful helpful in your
work to donate to his patreon campaign
native script view also reached 100
three days ago I don't know if you know
it but Jan looper is gonna tell you more
about it later in her talk and we also
are seeing a lot of better integrations
with external tools vs code you probably
have used vs code with data and you know
it's a it's a fantastic stanchion and
the author Vader now works on the vs
code team to improve you support and
they recently shipped a feature that
allows you to directly debug view
applications inside vs code and send
code sandbox provides an ally service
that allows you to create edit view
applications using single file
components directly in your browser you
don't even need to use the CLI to
scaffold anything this is also great for
prototyping and debugging making bug
reports prettier the code formatter
added support for view single file
conferencing 1.1 so it automatically
formats the code inside your script
blocks and even I believe it also
formats the Style section in your single
file components as well ionic 4 has been
built from the ground up using web
components and now it works with view as
well so they're having some tutorials
floating around as well so a lot of
external tools are also getting better
view support ok so now this thing that I
want to talk about which is something
I've been working on for the past two
months pretty intensively and it's the
next generation of the view CLI
so in the past in the prior generation
of DCI the two point ax versions have
some problems the goal was of the view
CLI was to provide a way for developers
to get up and running with view
applications as fast possible
unfortunately the the complexity in the
current front and tooling ecosystem
requires a lot of boil
plate and hand wiring if you want to set
up everything from scratch which is why
we provided the CII in the first place
however as we maintain the original
template we start to realize there are
some problems that the previous approach
did not address for example two point ax
templates are not upgradeable once you
scaffold a project you're completely on
your own consider your it's similar to
using create reactive and you're already
ejected from from the get-go alright so
there are not a prett upgrade but
especially if you have edited the
configurations yourself naked
configuration files inside the project
are also intimidating so if if you've
cracked open the build directory in a
two point xvi project you probably know
what I mean the web pack configuration
files are quite long and takes a quite
takes a bit of webpack expertise to
understand and be able to modify
anything template maintenance also
becomes more and more difficult so Linus
has been working on making the web pack
template for a while and we start to
realize because of all the features all
the possible permutations combinations
of different features having them all
handled at the template layer inside a
web CLI template was becoming
increasingly difficult you will have a
lot of statements that's cramming
together just trying to get the pendants
ease right and and most importantly in a
single file you will see concerns from
several different aspect of the template
for example in the package.json file you
will see a lot of candy in the template
you will see a lot of conditional blocks
from the unit testing aspect of it from
the end-to-end testing part of it and
from other features every feature will
need to inject something into package
JSON and the file just becomes bloated
and really hard to maintain and finally
for templates need to constantly sync
with upstream so last year the Kroll
team stepped they they forked the
original official web pack template and
they worked on a PW template
so some of you might have used that
template and that template worked really
well when it was first forked but as the
the upstream web patent play start to
evolve and we're making more changes we
required menu effort to to sync all
those changes downstream to the PW
template and that created discrepancy
between the two versions and if the the
maintainer of the PW template didn't
pull the changes downstream in time
there are differences in the build
setups between the two templates so we
want to address these problems so we
looked at a lot of existing solutions in
the ecosystem obviously there's Crete we
act out but the approach in my opinion
is a bit extreme because it's either use
use it's just that like it is or you
inject if you want to tweak the webpack
traffic so I want to create create a
cooling system that allows you to config
can figure the internal webpack
configuration if you want to but I don't
necessarily want to force users to eat
to eject because when once you eject
you're on your own you can no longer
update when there are upstream updates
there is another great inspiration some
of you might have you have used the POI
which is a great tool in the view
ecosystem by egoist and poi is great in
the sense that it has this core webpack
configuration that's abstracted away
using webpack chain and different pieces
functionality can be added to your base
app in the form of plugins or presets so
each preset will inject additional
weapon webpack configurations before it
finally gets resolving to the raw a
packin configuration the the issue is
POI is that it doesn't come with
scaffolding and scaffolding is still an
important part of the CLI
so poi is meant to be this really fast
get going tool you install it and you
can just create a single file and can
start using it
but it doesn't help you with structuring
things it doesn't help you say when I
want unit testing into end testing
typescript everything together I want to
have the project that's ready to go with
all the necessary files generated for me
so this is how the new VCI is born it's
it's very heavily inspired by poi and it
uses a plug-in based architecture it's
zero Copic by default so if you use it
and you're happy with the default config
in most cases you don't need to do
anything but everything is still
configurable without the need to eject
and this is how it looks like so I'm
gonna take a risk and just do some live
demonstration all right so this is what
happens when you use installed a new VCR
and use the view command so you can see
there is the commands include create and
Vulcan spec serve and dolt
so in it is really just an alias to the
old view in it but the new view creates
looks like this so lets you create low
and as you can see I have some presets
already so this is a safe preset from
from my prior experiments but just to
show how things work when you run it for
the first time you'll see the default
and manually select features and but in
most cases you want to customize things
by going with manually select and it's
it comes with a lot of built-in features
so first-class typescript support let's
just pick everything progressive web app
support router of UX CSS preprocessors
linger unit testing into and testing
let's take everything so class style
component syntax allows you to write
components using a class-based syntax
well just for the sake of demonstration
why not we can also use babel alongside
typescript so this allowed this allows
typescript to only do the compiler the
trans violation from typescript to yeah
2015 and the rest of the bail pipeline
will be delegated to Babel because we
can use Babel preset ends to
intelligently determining what polyfills
to include in your app and our Babel
configuration reads the browser list
targeting a package.json so which is
also used by autoprefixer so once you
set the range of browsers you want to
support Babel and post CSS well
intelligently determine the the Auto
prefixing and polyfill needs in your app
you can pick a CSS preprocessor and
comes with linker setups so you can use
yes linked with Airbnb standard prettier
even so let's use that we also have link
are sailing on Ling and six uncommit
unit testing with jest and end-to-end
testing with Cypress which is its chrome
only but with the great really great
interactive mode and Nightwatch which is
lanthanum based which allows you to run
tests seem more real browsers let's go
with Cypress for now and you can put
your configuration in dedicated files or
impact JSON depending on your personal
tastes and you can choose to save this
preset for a future project so once you
are happy with the configuration save it
and next time you create your new
project you don't need to fill out all
of these again you just use the preset
so I'll skip the save for now okay so
this warning is because our parser is
our typescript is using 2.7 and the
parser supports it actually works pretty
well with 2.7 it's just it decides to
throw a warning there so let's go into
the project and take a look and okay
let's I'm gonna make the font size
really big
oops okay and so it well this is pretty
small right but you can see it
scaffolded all the files and most
important thing is in the package.json
so you can see the scripts here we have
so all the plugins have injected the
scripts for them increasingly
all the features that you just saw that
we picked just now are implemented in
the form of plugins and each thumb for
example the the unit test plugging
injects this command into package.json
the n2m plugging injects this command
into package asa and the unit tests
plugging also injects the view CA
service test command into the service so
the service is a runtime package that is
locally installed into your project so
once the project has been created all
the dependencies that it needs is
included in its dependent in its package
Ehsan so once created this path this
project can jibs just be committed and
to get sent to another developer and
they can just npm install with all the
dependencies and they can get up and
running even without you see how i and
so let's run the server i hope it works
oops alright so the new app and it comes
with all these links to it automatically
infers the links to the documentation
based on the public plugins you've
picked okay so another thing i want to
show is although it's great that you can
scaffold a DCI project with all the
dependencies built-in sometimes you just
don't want to wait for the npm install
so here's a cool thing you can do I'll
just create something template hello UJS
Amsterdam
okay so we have the app app view I don't
know if you can see it but now I say you
serve app top view whoops
haha okay let's see
right because I didn't wrap it in a root
note okay so with this file
so you can start rapidly prototyping
applicative UJS applications with just
literally a single view file from the
command line
once you install a global package cup
you see our service global and this you
can also do view build laptop view which
will produce a bundle and you can deploy
this it's a it's you can actually build
build prototype and deploy apps just
without any NPM dependencies and there
is also if you build targets web
component and I need to give it the name
with a - so my app so this great still
creates a JavaScript file but this
javascript file contains a real weapon
custom element once you include this
file into your page it will register a
custom element called my app and then
you can just use this my app element
just like a normal Dom element you don't
even need to so you need to do need to
include a view runtime on the page but
when you're actually using the element
itself it doesn't matter if it's used in
a view app or not you can use it in any
app you can use in react and angular or
just vanilla JavaScript
okay so let's also go to the hello app
and we can do something like your arm
dode forget WC async and give it a grip
pattern so this command will find all
the view files in your project and build
it into a cut sled bundle of web
components so you will have
now let's build whoops okay that one
felt so let's see what is going on how
scoped I'll skip this one because uh but
you get the idea we'll have a bundle of
multiple multiple javascript files and
the cool thing is you will get an entry
chunk the entry chunk well in most cases
be only seven KB minified and three kb
gzipped and you include that one file it
registers all the view components that
you've just spilt into real custom
elements and then you can just directly
use those custom elements and when an
element custom element instance is
actually encountered on the page it will
then fetch the internal and the
implementation of the internal view
component on demand so you get this
really load on demand lazy loaded custom
elements but you still get the exact
same development experience of the
familiar view single file components in
hot reload during development and all
the tool change that comes with view CLI
you can enjoy those benefits different
development but during are when you want
to deploy it you can still deploy it as
a sync web components so the CI also
comes with a lot of flexibility so the
internal web pack configuration is after
act with web pack chain and can be
modified in viewed on convict j/s so if
you're a curious about how this works
you can read the documentation it's
already up on github and it's very quite
straightforward to modify small pieces
of web web pack configurations and
babble posting assistant yes link can
all be configured with their respective
configuration files plus we also want to
open up the extensibility of the CI
because the cool thing about the
previous generation the CLI was that the
community could create custom templates
and we want to still enable that to a
certain extent too in the new API
although then the the next generation of
the CLI is is
0co fake but since there is no more
template to pick there's just one
default template but it's still possible
to inject a lot of custom behavior into
the CLI by writing custom plugins so
plugins are able to modify the internal
attack configuration they can inject
file generators they can have their own
custom prompts when you do view invoke
and they can also ingest custom commands
in fact most of these built-in features
like typescript and - and testing unit
testing they're all implemented using
the same standard plugging API so if you
want to you can write your own blocking
API your own plugging that implements a
special integration into the vcli
for something special that you want so
I'll be releasing its entering data so
before this it was still in alpha stage
but I think it's pretty stable now so
VCR 3.0 will being data today
[Applause]
thank you and after that a few old notes
on what's coming next
wet pack for just came out of the door
it's a maiden now and we being in close
collaboration with webpack team they're
keeping us up to date on upgrading some
important plugins that were in the
webpack ecosystem making sure they're
compatible with web app for and we're
going to upgrade to web pack for as soon
as we can
and because because it comes with some
really great performance boosts 2.6
which is the next minor that we'll be
working on it's gonna ship with an ESM
yes modules browser build so you can use
script type module to import viewed I am
NOT a as directly in the browser without
a build step yes modules directly in the
browser it's gonna also come with better
asynchronous and error handling so in
2.5 we improve error handling but one
thing that we overlooked with
asynchronous errors and want to improve
that and then you'll see better warning
outfit as well so the view runtime
itself reports warnings when you have
some syntax errors in the template but
by default doesn't come with line
numbers before but there is a great poor
request.open right now which we will
merge soon that will give you line
numbers and even code frames when you
have a syntax error you know template
and then we'll also have before iterator
support so we're gonna have support from
that and set in view for as well and
then there's also going to be 2.6 next
so this next branch is going to be a
branch that will drop older browser
support it will only support latest
browsers browser support latest ES
features so for example proxies so yes
2015 proxies is very cool and we're
gonna use proxies to to replace the
current reactivity system and upgrade
the code base to leverage the latest ES
features but the API will remain the
remain the same there will be maybe one
percent of small income incompatible 'no
spot 99 percent api remains the same in
in majority of the cases you should as
well as you you're willing to drop
support for some of the older browsers
you should be able to just migrate over
without doing anything both versions
will be maintained in parallel and so
until the you do de browsers actually
phases out and will then drop support
for the for the legacy branch we're also
planning to simplify the API of UX
considering all the new es features
especially async/await so one the reason
that we have mutations actually
separated in view X right now is because
it allows us to better handle a
synchronicity
but with async rate we are exploring
some new possibilities and some of the
proposals are pretty exciting and we
will likely eliminate the separation of
actions mutations all together so you
can just write actions
and that's all I have for today so thank
you
[Music]